[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Hello.
I'm Jen Person for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
We recently launched
the Security
in GCP Specialization, our
latest on-demand training
course.
It introduces you
to Google's approach
to security in
the cloud, and how
to deploy and manage components
of a secured GCP solution.
Some background and a
list of the focus areas
are on the post linked
in the description below.
Handling large
amounts of deletes
is an important part
of scaling a database.
We've just made
this a lot easier
with the Firebase
Realtime Database
by introducing a new way
to efficiently perform
large deletes.
Examples and a link to
the docs are on the post.
You can now sign into Firebase
Auth using Microsoft and Yahoo
as new federated
identity providers,
joining Google,
Facebook, and Twitter.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Google's Science
Journal app enables
you to use sensors in
your mobile devices
to perform science experiments,
and it's now open-source.
For some screenshots and
a link to the GitHub repo,
check out the post
We are now accepting
applications
from university students
who want to participate
in Google Summer of Code 2019.
If you'd like to hone
your software development
skills while doing good for
the open-source community,
head on over to the
post for all the links.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Please remember-- nope.
SPEAKER 1: Remember?
JEN PERSON: Mem, mem, mem,
mem, mem, mem, mem, mem.
SPEAKER 1: Do you remember?
JEN PERSON: (SINGING) The
21st night of September?
OK.